welcome to the egging phase course
this course has been designed to teach
you all about the egging face ecosystem
how to use the dataset and model hub as
well as all our open source libraries
here is the table of contents as you can
see it's divided in three sections which
become progressively more advanced
at this stage the first two sections
have been released
the first will teach you the basics of
how to use a transformer model find you
need on your own data set and share the
result with the community
the second we'll dive deeper into our
libraries and teach you how to tackle
any nlp task
we are actively working on the last one
and hope to have it ready for you for
the spring of 2022
the first chapter requires no technical
knowledge and is a good introduction to
learn what transformers model can do and
how they could be of use to you or your
company
the next chapters require a good
knowledge of python and some basic
knowledge of machine learning and deep
learning
if you don't know what a training and
validation set are or what gradient
descent means you should look at an
introductory course such as the ones
published by deep learning dot ai of as
detail
it's also best if you have some basics
in one deep learning framework by
torture tensorflow
each part of the material introduced in
this course has a version in both those
frameworks so you'll be able to pick the
one you are most comfortable with
this is the team that developed this
course i'll now let each of the speakers
introduce themselves briefly
hi my name is matthew and i'm a machine
learning engineer at hugging face i work
on the open source team and i'm
responsible for maintaining particularly
the tensorflow code there
previously i was a machine learning
engineer at parsley who have recently
been acquired by automatic and i was a
postdoctoral researcher before that at
trinity college dublin in ireland
working on computational genetics and
retinal disease
hi i'm lysander i'm a machine learning
engineer at hugging face and i'm
specifically part of the open source
team
i've been at hugging face for a few
years now and alongside my team members
i've been working on most of the tools
that you'll get to see in this course
hi
i'm silva i'm a research engineer at
dockyface and one of the main
maintainers of the transformers library
previously i worked at fast.ai where i
helped develop the fastai library as
well as the online book
before that i was a math and computer
science teacher in france
hi my name is sasha and i'm a researcher
at hugging face working on the ethical
environmental and social impacts of
machine learning models
previously i was a postdoctoral
researcher at mila university of
montreal and i also worked as an applied
ai researcher for the united nations
global pulse i've been involved in
projects such as code carbon and the
machine learning impacts calculator to
measure the carbon footprint of machine
learning
hi i'm marve and i'm a developer
advocate at hugging face
previously i was working as a machine
learning engineer building nlp tools and
chat bots
currently i'm working to improve the hub
and democratize machine learning
hello everyone
my name is lucille and i'm a machine
learning engineer at oregon faith
to tell you in two sentences who i am i
work on the development and support of
open source tools
and i also participate in several
research projects in the field of
natural language processing
g'day there i'm lewis and i'm a machine
learning engineer in the open source
team at hugging face
i'm passionate about developing tools
for the nlp community and you'll see me
at many of hugging faces outreach
activities
before joining hugging face i spent
several years developing machine
learning applications for startups and
enterprises in the domains of nlp
topological data analysis and time
series
in a former life i was a theoretical
physicist where i researched particle
collisions at the large hadron collider
in cern
hey i'm leandro and i'm a machine
learning engineer in the open source
team at hugging face
before joining hugging face i worked as
a data scientist in switzerland and have
taught data science at university